(voices murmuring)
- [Caitlin] Using Bitcoin to buy clothes,
snacks, even the daily
newspaper instead of US dollars
is now an option to the
people in El Salvador
as the country becomes
the first in the world
to adopt the volatile crypto
as its national currency.
It's a big test for
Bitcoin in the real world,
and for Salvadorans.
To get them started,
the government is giving $30 to people
who sign up to an e-wallet called Chivo,
which allows for the automatic conversion
of dollars to Bitcoin and vice versa.
While some businesses welcome
this crypto experiment,
80% of Salvadorians have little
or no confidence in Bitcoin.
And some have opposed the move.
- One big reason is because
people don't want their wages
to be denominated in Bitcoin.
It's related to the sharp fluctuations
in value that Bitcoin has.
Also, a lot of people
think that El Salvador
is not really prepared
for this type of adoption.
A lot of people don't have smartphones,
and if they do, they
don't have data plans.
(people clapping)
- And I worked really hard,
and I lived there, and I
got to know the community,
and I made friends that I hope
will be at my wedding some day.
And so with all that being said,
I'd like to invite.
- [Caitlin] El Salvador's
president announced the plan
in June, making a surprise
appearance via video link
at a Bitcoin conference
being held in Miami.
- In the short-term,
this will generate jobs
and help provide financial inclusion
to thousands outside the formal economy.
- [Caitlin] President Bukele has said
that adopting Bitcoin
will, among other things,
attract foreign investment
and foster cheaper financial services.
But it also risks wrecking
El Salvador's $26 billion economy.
Bitcoin is known for its big swings
with huge sell-offs that
can be triggered by a tweet.
And its decentralized
system opens the doors
to anonymous and illicit transactions,
like money laundering or ransom
payments, economists say.
The government's plan has sparked protests
in the impoverished
Central American nation.
(shouting in foreign language)
- The law was passed in a matter of hours
without discussion with stakeholders.
The private sector was never consulted.
The same goes for labor unions
or other segments of society.
So it was, in a way, imposed,
and this comes at a time
when El Salvador is facing
some economic headwinds.
They have a very
significant budget deficit.
They are in talks
with the International Monetary Fund
to get a financial aid
package of 1.3 billion.
- [Caitlin] El Salvador's Finance Minister
said he doesn't expect
Bitcoin's volatility
to pose a problem,
and that the instant convertibility
of Bitcoin to dollars via Chivo
is likely to be sufficient.
Financial institutions
will also be required
to alert customers of
Bitcoin's volatility.
Bitcoin is currently trading
at around $50,000 each.
Bitcoin's adoption as
legal tender in El Salvador
is unprecedented, and this experiment
is going to be closely monitored
by crypto advocates, global
financial institutions,
and governments around the world
to see how it works, how effective it is,
and what the consequences could be.
(food frying)
(dramatic music)